[Applaudissements]
car j'arrive la gécamines t'as kiffé
barbe il a tu avais tu n'as pas trouvé
il n'a jamais aussi bon que dans bull
mais il est formidable il est vachement
bien c'est une équipe et jusqu'en bas là
mais il est complètement d'accalmie
qu'est-ce qui m'a erreurs dans sa
chronique ce soir que vit dans l'univers
et planète et pmp quel est le programme
du soir
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand il est là et là tu sortais à 25 cm
il juste dans l'indre et loire
je suis à 3 m à 3 m dans sa dimension
c'est vachement l'europe à mettre 3 km
trois années lumières jetées mode tu
peux pas me fermer ta gueule
maxime s'explique je suis fan moi aussi
tu le sais ou mamie c'est green adam
était le meilleur du monde l'a jamais il
réalise un rêve de gosse j'ai jamais vu
un accident a nécessité en faisant vivre
toutes manquées dit
hélas un peu moins rigoler c'est quand
il va comprendre que le démaquillage qui
n'est pas gagné la fête bleue comme sa
presse et karcher et compagnie
apparemment les maquillages sont allés
une chance et de l'huile
ah ouais ça fasse davantage sur les
choses intéressantes mais contador au
thème aussi alors on va aller coûte
maintenant qu'elle me combat ouais bercy
et areva ne tue pas disparaître fait
d'une disparition des trucs et l'essor
et la vie est vite à vincent lagaf
bonsoir autant de chérioux camille
combal c'est gentil merci à lui aussi il
adore ce que tu fais d'ailleurs mais
repart avec mon disque d'or bon elle
voulait commencer du couple pour finir
fauveau fort des mailles ont consacré 24
à celle ci s'est passé à la télé très
très très très haut très vite puis c'est
le principe c'est parfois en hiver c'est
parti à l'hôtel une remarque d'un
concurrent sur l'âge des proprios mon
avis sont partis pour payer le double en
vous avez échappé une légère différence
d'âge et
combien décor 19 ans je redis que des
chiffres et des lettres à perte en ait
fait une petite remarque sur le tee
shirt de lolo romejko l'eau le prend mal
l'autre assume plus du tout une vraie
galère moi j'avais un t-shirt aussi et
marc est grand et intelligent j'ai
arrêté de le mettre à yale oui oui
valait mieux pourquoi on va enchaîner
sur la ligne du rer c le poteau maxime
guen il a bien galéré aujourd'hui un
pour venir au studio pour s'occuper il a
tout donné dans sa deuxième phase on l'a
très bien c'est bien celle qui n'a
vraiment tous les talents si emmanuel
macron scénarii t du 13 heures de jean
pierre pernaut dans une salle de classe
dans l'orne
on a pu noter on a pu noter que dès que
le président voulait parler d'un sujet
jpp était toujours à la bourre à s'il
voulait en parler plus tard tous les
enfants en cm2 sachez bien lire écrire
compter et bien ce qu'on reparlera tout
à l'heure de l'école qu'ils soient au
chômage ils étaient 70 à tout à l'heure
avec les impôts qui la terre enfin tout
à l'heure avec d'investissement enfin
bravo un instant il avait jamais
d'ailleurs la grille et isabelle
morini-bosc du groupe m6 elle est
toxique de soirée
[Applaudissements]
allez vous vous êtes très bien derrière
l'objectif également les deux là quand
je vois à côté ça fait quand même
flipper les deux là on n'est rien de
changé mais c'est pas les pas des idées
derrière sa tête avait bouclé n'a rien à
voir java christine vous en pleine forme
et regarder tourner votre tête à droite
non à droite voilà les tournées vote à
gauche elle c'est ça voilà arrivée
d'étape comme ça c'est ça joker allez
merci vidi vici
ça veut dire j'ai ma télé fin les
chaînes info fond je crois j'ai pris des
nouvelles de notre premier ministre
edouard philippe arles 8 en asie dans
les locaux de la république en marche
mais un petit peu aller voir ce qui se
passait dans le mouvement alors les gens
lui présente des militants qu'il connaît
forcément pas vraiment en revanche les
militantes
il en connaît une sur dehors bonjour
alors oui oh ça commence un deuxième bon
jour mais là je n'en connais pas du tout
à la marche alors les grandes gueules de
rmc il a fait une petite bafouille sur
l'angle jpp tu sens qu'il est plus
journal du hard que journal de 13h à
lunel en direction mc bfm tv aujourd'hui
à 13 heures jean-pierre porn pernot ires
regardez bien ce monsieur le président
des maires d'île de france stéphane
baudet il est invité en duplex j'ai
jamais vu un gars passe de aussi vite de
jeu fécond avec mes potes je suis méga
concentrer pour parler en direct
barthélémy bolo et sur place ce matin
barthélémy vous êtes aux côtés de
stéphane beaudet
oui stéphane modec élu maire de
courcouronnes et qui est président de
l'association grosse parka direct
grondera sera bon j'ai regarder m6 aussi
beaucoup de quoi hashtag ménagères bacs
j'aime bien j'ai regardé un petit peu la
personne évidemment rien à oui bah oui
mais d'abord top chef
parce qu'un candidat qui s'appelle
camille parce que c'est avant tout un
prénom de garçon
il est hyper fort aux cuisines mais
niveau image il te coupent l'appétit dia
et l'oscar du plus bel effet kadri lui
et
y'a rien il ya beaucoup dessus les tout
lisse comme la bonne mais roubaix
donc c'est un total c'est sympa cyril
mardi soldes étiez chez stéphane plaza
vous avez vraiment 1000 à la main à la
pâte
vous n'avez pas et décoller la moquette
tout ça dans la bonne humeur où la
comparaison on a le résultat la maison
avant la venue de cyril et voici la
maison après la venue de cyril très cool
avec ce n'est pas le cas de ceux qui
sait parler aux fans stéphane plaza qui
participent à l'émission regardez une
fille voilà son rêve se réalise et
stéphane plaza son idole va lui vendre
son appart et voilà que c'est donc
aujourd'hui que stéphane plaza vient
aider amanda à vendre sa maison
ah c'est toi que je viens voir fais moi
qu'est ce que c'est que cette couleur de
jouer cette voiture qui file à ma nature
c'est cependant qu'on lève il est nature
et découvertes comme toi tu aimes offrir
un tel te découvrir dans son ghetto il
passe à vous et gardez le même une
fouille à griffin cool si toi aussi tu
filmes primeur victimes au lancement
c'est à regarder midi en france parce
que tu as une vie de merde tape dans tes
mains autant aujourd'hui une journaliste
en duplex d'un musée sur le roc un musée
consacré au rock and roll elle a
interviewé le pape du rock and roll the
legend c'est simple on a été tous sur le
popotin à la rédac on s'est dit ça est
un rockeur de dengue quoi formidable
guitare électrique pour nous raconter ce
musée je suis avec le pape
jack and world eric bonjour eric bonjour
c'est bien alerte le quart des 11 alors
que tout le monde à la carra tôt par
kelly c'est gilles verdez tapis dans
l'ombre qui a conquis son coeur on a
retrouvé leurs enfants à la télé ils
sont pas si je suis le vers les musiques
en parler de taxi 5
c'est hyper classe y apprend qu'elle
manie qu'ont laissé une grosse dédicace
à william leymergie
mais c'est la case des 10 la plus courte
et la plus triste que j'ai vu de ma vie
pas sûr qu'il est à l'avant première
c'est que ça va cartonner mais attendez
williams j'avais un d'un des petits
trucs pour vous est-ce que je crois que
frank et malik vous aime bien du coup il
avait un petit moucheron tendance à se
produire
les organes elle est tellement court
qu'à la fin ils sont obligés de figer
l'image que ça fasse un peu moins le
côté d'eux m'a dit qu'il est j'ai fait
un bon jour william brock et manic vous
aime bien du coup il avait un petit
moment
me gioia
mais qu'en est il des amis d'enfance et
non c'est pourquoi la lancée chebeya
même image f1 il fondit pause c'était
moi même passé y sont quand même sympa
ils ont remis un petit ballon 500
millions a justement mardi mardi soir
malik était sur ce plateau grâce à lui
j'ai fait la rencontre de cystite du
parc de soucis bien mais on a eu droit
tous les deux donc par pure vengeance
j'ai décidé de regarder nos terres
inconnues sur franck labbé et autant
maliki était parfait dans le tag les
parfaits dans taxi 50 ans fois qu'ils
attendent un peu pour indiana jones is
magic bolides et déjà il a des remarques
ultra pertinentes dès le petit déj
notamment sur un jus de pomme fait
maison
je tombe désespéré il a un goût de pomme
nick a aussi fait de la tyrolienne un
moment toujours impressionnant 1
on a pu découvrir le côté têtes brûlées
de malik qui s'en sont aussi bien que
tous les gars sur le web
[Musique]
or loupé une fois dans l'eau c'est là
que mal une rupture avec la nature il
prend du plaisir ils en profitent ils
aiment l'eau 50% 5 au compteur c'est lui
g
à plusieurs
malika et pour le plaisir petit cadeau
on a récupéré la voix off d'un reportage
sur les croisières pour illustrer le
périple de malik hashtag sissi duparc
malik never forget est ce sont les
nouvelles vacances à la mode
les croisières cet après midi première
escale au loin mykonos l'une des îles
les plus connus des cyclades simulateur
de bagues bas robotisés ou même
tyrolienne 3 yards en sont quittes
friendly il y en a pour tous les goûts
mais la journée de nos vacanciers est
loin d'être terminée car à la tombée de
la nuit ils peuvent profiter de
nombreuses animations toujours
différente ce qui démontre plaisir non
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas dit qu'il va m'envoyer un
message je veux que l'histoire s'est dit
toi écrit frère c'est kiwi des hommes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
justes a dit me donne un coup de main
on étudie william leymergie n'a que soit
sa dette jeudi à qui on peut faire des
coups quoi williams n'a pas dû plaire à
tous qu'ils étaient bons joueurs qui
sont vertes elle l'a fait à la fin dans
c'est au programme tous les matins h f
via en plateau montrer la recette qui
prépare en direct dès ce matin tu sens
que sophie davant elle s'en fout
complètement l écoute pas elle enchaîne
son respect pour le gagner et donc on
facture ce pigeon ou ce poulet longtemps
dans un bouillon et prend les miettes on
l'a roulé noir avec toute cette farce
tous ces ingrédients génial c'est ici on
peut l'appeler autrement moi je
l'appelais au bout j'ai fait les projets
qu m
elle s'en fout
2 faustine bollaert recevez une maman
qui vient avec sa petite fille sur le
plateau et on sait les enfants sont
formidables mais n'hésite pas de foot la
vente à la télé non pas le filtre gènes
des enfants oui on va très fier elle
doit être sacrément chaud journal indien
non oui oui oui avec simplement évoqué
le comportement ils ont avec l autre
maman à 30 ans un petit garçon qui
trouve parfaitement ce que sa maman
vient dire on n'aurait pas pu fermer
beaucoup plus occupé des filles rien n'a
donc du coup il est beaucoup plus proche
de moi donc c'est tout le temps maman
maman et voilà les images de sport west
bay avait la ligue des champions il ya
quelques jours vous le savez que des
scénarios improbables et avec la roma
qui a complètement renversé le barça
alors on voulait juste vous montrer les
commentateurs a déduit et commentateurs
italiens comique les plombs c'est ouf
c'est pas christian jeanpierre les gars
voir leur équipe renverser le plus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'entraîneur de manchester city fait
boire viol accès très rapide ce matin et
les vénère mais dès qu'ils vivent ici
redevient z c'est chelou
aux essais chez rogers
[Applaudissements]
tu social et sur une chaîne polonaise
regarder ça c'est incroyable de sports
extrêmes on va trouver la journaliste
qui veut être très près des pilotes
peut-être trop tous avec des jet skis
james bond passant mon avis elle se dit
ça va être marrant mais satan je le vois
venir le coup de gueule non ouais bah
c'est pas encore encore encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien ça c'est bon ça fait ça
avec moi ça donnez moi ça sait pas qui
fait toi et moi ça qui n'a donné moi
c'est un regard des hommes et l'autre
ouais mais on reconnaît votre plume
notre île oui une info médias vous
prenez vous laisser non je laisse mon
[Rires]
rapport on va parler de motocross c'est
un sport qui est très attractif comme ça
sports mécaniques très attractif
pourquoi ça ne passe jamais télévision
alors qu'il ya beaucoup de sponsors qui
pourraient parce qu'au bout d'un tour
les sponsors ce ne sont plus visibles à
cause de la boue donc faire des passes
normal c'est pas un week-end tu feras
pas de toi aussi tu as nos parents
week-end par huissier loi dati renac
sympa du tout d'où l'avantagé du jet-ski
journal
pour camille pascal gérant faire un
petit mois c'est mais voilà
[Applaudissements]
non je le suis mais là c'est mes
fringues personnes pressées à cela dit
ouais blanc sur blanc ça peut être jolie
buy american bon bah non mais j'ai fini
voulait revoir
maliki fait une dédicace à l'icam voilà
à william leymergie mais tu sens que
c'est pas bien qui sait voilà il m'a dit
on aurait pu lui dire c'est pour toufik
mon coup mais attendez williams j'avais
un talent des petits trucs pour vous
est-ce que je crois que frank et malik
vous aime bien du coup il avait un petit
moucheron tendance première vision
williams
[Applaudissements]